just as world war 1 was beginning in
august of 1914 the ottoman empire had
not as yet taken sides but there were
many factors that were already pushing
them along the sides or having them lean
towards the central powers first of all
there was no there was no love between
them and the russian empire on top of
that they already had close relations
with the germans and on top of that in
august of 1914 they saw the germans were
able to roll through belgium as they
were executing on the first few stages
of the schlieffen plan so that was
enough to convince the turks that hey
maybe we should join the the war on the
side of the central powers and to kind
of fur their first engagement in that
war was to start to bombard russian
ports in the black sea which they did in
late october of 1914. they made bombards
there there there which essentially was
the trigger or was their kind of their
way of saying hey we're in this war on
the side of the central powers a few
days later in early november you have
war officially declared from the antant
against the ottoman empire so while all
of this was happening you now have the
ottomans officially part of the central
powers as we enter into november 1914.
let's turn our attention to the british
empire the for the allies at least so
far and at the the fall of 1914 it was
not looking so good the germans were
able to roll through belgium they were
making offensive gains it was starting
to look a little bit more like a
stalemate as we get into the end of 1914
but it was definitely not looking good
for the allies the germans were able to
gain a lot of ground and there were
forces within the british military that
were in favor of using their naval power
to open up another front and in
particular the other front that they
wanted to open up was with the ottomans
they were eager in order to capture the
dardanelles and you can't see it that
well in this diagram we'll zoom in on it
in a second the dardanelles is this
straight right over here that connects
the aegean sea with this with the sea of
marmara
and the reason why this was of interest
to the british or to the allies is that
would open up shipping channels from the
mediterranean through the aegean through
the dardanelles into the sea of marmara
through the bosphorus which is this
straight right over here that you can't
see through well into the black sea that
would allow the allies to reconnect with
their russian with the russian allies
fighting on the eastern front allow them
to supply arms allow them to supply aid
and also allow allow them to provide
support in the black sea where now you
have russia in an ongoing naval conflict
with the central powers and the
strongest proponent of the strategy of
opening up this new naval front was
winston churchill who i'm sure you you
might have heard of he's a prominent
figure in world war ii in world war ii
he is the prime minister of the united
kingdom but at this point he's just the
first not i shouldn't just say just he's
still a very high position he's the
first lord of the admiralty and if
you're an american it's like the
equivalent of the secretary of the navy
and he was really in favor of trying to
capture the straits the the the turkish
traits the dardanelles the sea of
marmara and the bosphorus so that they
could connect with the russians so they
could connect and arm the russians in
the black sea now most folks who heard
about this plan were not that
enthusiastic about it and that was
because of how protected the dardanelles
were and i'm now going to zoom in on
about this part right over here so let's
zoom in
on the dardanelles and this right over
here is a zoomed in version of the
dardanelles this is a little bit more
zoomed out this is the dardanelles right
over here this right over here is the
gallipoli peninsula this is the
gallipoli palence zoomed in a little bit
and then you have here you don't see it
that well on this map but on on this map
right over here you have the sea of
marmara and these maps these old maps
are actually quite quite fascinating
because they show you why a purely naval
offensive year was not that good of an
idea
these red lines that you see that are
numbered you see literally number one
number two number three the legend here
tells you that those are belts of mines
and they tell you exactly how many mines
are in those belts these little x
looking things right over here these are
forts that are sitting on the coast on
either side of the dardanelles ready to
bombard any ships that might try to make
their way through the dardanelles there
are some forts right over here at the
opening this right over here is a
separate battery so this is not a very a
very hospitable environment to try to
invade with ships but despite that
winston churchill was able to have his
way and so in 1915
february
1915 you have an allied naval offensive
that tries to capture the dardanelles
now based on all of the foreshadowing
that i've just given you you might
imagine that this offensive was not that
successful in fact it was a bit of a
disaster in fact it was not successful
but the allies were not ready and
winston churchill was not ready to to
give up just yet they recognized okay
just doing it purely on a naval basis
did not work we need to have ground
forces as well that can maybe help
capture that can maybe help capture some
of the high ground some of the high
ground on either side of the dardanelles
maybe capture some key strategic
positions from which they can start to
take they can start to take out some of
these forts and some of these batteries
and that'll give us the protection give
the allies the protection in order to be
able to make their way and take control
of the dardanelles followed by the sea
of marmara and and the bosphorus
so
in march or march was the time by the
time that they kind of recognized that
the the naval operation was going to
fail by april 25th
on april
april 25th
1915. and this is a very important date
especially for australians and new
zealanders i believe new zealanders is
the word for someone who is from new
zealand you have a ground assault on the
gallipoli peninsula and that's why it's
often called the gallipoli campaign so
this right over here is the gallipoli
gallipoli
gallipoli peninsula and they the ground
troops attacked in two places or they
made their landfall in two places right
over here at the tip of the peninsula
right over here at heli's and then
further up the peninsula further up the
peninsula right over and it's not
labeled as well right over here but
right over
right in
this region right over here which is now
known and you see a little bit clearer
right over here which was named anzac
cove
and anzac
anzac stands for australian and new
zealand
army
corps and this is a huge day in the
history of australia new zealand
they were new dominions they were part
of the formerly part of the british
empire they were starting to exert a
little bit more independence they were
they were the the major force as you can
imagine right here at anzac cove and
even though that this was a huge debacle
for the allies it's kind of a it's an
important day in the military history of
these countries and it's a day of
remembrance and that's why april 25th is
called anzac day in austria new zealand
to commemorate this battle this campaign
but also other military
battles and victories that may have
happened it's kind of the equivalent of
of their of their veterans day but
needless to say april 25th you have they
you have two ground assaults trying to
capture the gallipoli peninsula
neither of them were able to reach their
reach their intended targets at some
point it started to just become a bit of
a protracted
unfortunately very bloody situation on
the allied side so let me make this
clear on the allied side
so the allies brought about 500 thousand
five hundred thousand troops to the
battle the ottomans
the ottomans
brought the estimates i've seen are in
excess of three hundred thousand troops
they already were able to control a lot
of the forts and the high ground so they
had the strategic advantage the allies
had 250
000 casualties this includes debts and
wounded the the ottomans the estimates
i've seen is about 200
200
000 casualties you have about 50 000
dead so 50 000 of the 250 000 of the
allied casualties were dead the the
ottomans the estimates i've seen have
about 60 000
sixty thousand dead
and of these numbers of the fifty
thousand dead approximately eleven
thousand
eleven thousand were from australia and
new zealand which is a huge number for
any country but especially countries as
small as population wise especially in
new zealand but even australia had a
fairly a fairly small population so as
we enter as we
start exiting 1915 it becomes clear that
this is a huge debacle for the allies
they have to retreat and the only
somewhat silver lining on this whole
thing for the allies was that the
retreat was able to be done in a fairly
fairly efficient way so the gallipoli
campaign huge disaster for the allies
winston churchill resigns his post in
disgrace he obviously is able to make a
comeback later on because he's prime
minister during world war ii
and it's a considered a huge victory for
the ottomans they were able to push back
this navel and this ground assault and
in particular you have a gentleman who
figures very largely about as large as
you can get in turkish history mustafa
kamal later to be known as mustafa kamal
ataturk later to be the kind of the
father of the turkish republic but this
is where he first laid his mark he was
the he was a commander of a division
that was able to hold its ground he
started he's starting to appear as a
military hero and so he was the ottomans
and mustafa kamal in particular were big
winners from the gallipoli campaign